We can improve the overall
hit latency of the cache
using a virtually accessed cache.
In that case,
the virtual address is what we use to
access the cache and get the data.
On a cache miss,
we would use the virtual address, to
tell us what the physical address is, so
that we can bring data into our cache.
But on cache hits, we can get the data
without doing the TLB access at all.
So the advantages of this virtually
accessed cache over the physically
accessed one are that
the overall hit time is just
the cache hit time with no
TLB latency added to it.
That's nice and
we don't need the TLB access on
cache hits, so we can save energy.
We like that too.
So we can see that
the virtually access cache
has the hit time that
adjust the cache hit time.
Because we use the virtual address to
access the cache and because of that
we get the data even without
address translation on a cache hit.
So we can only access the TLB on a miss,
which saves us TLB misses and
saves energy which is also nice.
So it looks like the virtual access
cache would win every time, so
why are we even considering
physically accessed caches?
Well, first of all, the TLB, in addition
to containing the translation for
the physical address,
also contains permissions that we need
to tell us whether we are allowed to
read or write or execute certain pages.
So even though we don't need
a physical address from the TLB in
order to get their data, we still need
to access the TLB even on cache hits
just to get the permissions that tell us
whether we are allowed to read, write,
or execute that location.
So this advantage really doesn't
exist in real processors.
A bigger problem is that
the virtual address
is specific to a particular process.
So if we were running one process and
filled the cache with it's data,
once we begin running another process
that other process will have virtual
addresses that might overlap with
the addresses from the previous process.
But they should be going
to different data.
Pretty much in the TLB there will be
different translations for that other
process, and we should be accessing
different actual memory locations.
Because our cache only knows about
virtual addresses in this case,
we now need to flush our cache meaning
remove all the data from it every
time we do a context switch.
Once we are switching
to another process,
we know that virtual addresses are
going to map to different locations, so
what we have to do is get rid of
everything we have in the cache.
This means that we have a burst of cache
misses every time we switch processes.
Processes are switched once
every millisecond or so, so
it doesn't sound like a big deal.
But keep in mind that
the cache can be large, so
it takes a lot of misses to
bring in the data into it.
So this is a disadvantage.